bindi Irwin names a koala after her
dancing with a Stars partner meet Derek
Hough from Australia who are actually
wildlife and I got to learn how to dance
yeah and it's all things honestly to
Derek but always believing the immune
just staying strong the 17 year old
jetted back to Australia after taking
home the Mirrorball trophy last month
and she's thanking Derek in the best way
ever
on Thursday the Australia Zoo posted
this pic of a koala writing quote check
out Derek Hough the Koala the cute
caption went on to say quote although he
may not be as smooth on the dance floor
or as light on his feet as his namesake
he sure is good at melting hearts but it
gets better
on Thursday bindi told Australian
morning show sunrise that the pro dancer
would be taking a trip down under to
meet the adorable animal do I am excited
because Derek will be visiting Australia
very soon so he'll be coming to
Australia to meet his own namesake and
by the way we're pretty sure Derek Hough
the Koala is just as photogenic as Derek
Hough the dancer